[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour un
nouveau numéro de sens public bienvenue
en étant ensemble pour 90 minutes de
débats et de reportage comme tous les
soirs à 18h et 22h sur Public Sénat et
voici le sommaire de ce 13 avril c'est
là 12e journée de mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites ambiance de
veiller d'armes à la veille de la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel la
réforme peut-elle être retoquée la
pression de la rue peut-être influencer
la décision des sages qu'elle sera la
stratégie de l'intersyndicale si le
texte est validé réponse de nos experts
dans un instant et puis notre second
débat porte sur la justice restaurative
vous ne savez peut-être pas ce que c'est
c'était également mon cas avant de
découvrir ce film je verrai toujours vos
visages
quand vous attaquez quelqu'un il y a pas
qu'une victime il y a d'autres victimes
derrière il y a des familles des coupes
des enfants on met des petites claques
c'est pour impressionner le déclaques
c'est des coups vrai j'ai l'impression
j'ai jamais rien décidé dans ma vie
assume nous sort pas tes excuses débiles
des victimes et des coupables réunies en
prison en séance collective pour réparer
les séquelles psychologiques des uns
éviter la récidive des autres mais aussi
des face à face entre une victime et son
bourreau c'est ça la justice
restaurative comment ça marche est-ce
que ça marche réponse dans 45 minutes
mais d'abord on retrouve Jonathan du
priez et Hugo Lemonnier dans la
manifestation parisienne place de la
Bastille moins de monde dans les rues
Jonathan peut-on pour autant parler
d'une team mobilisation
en tout cas Thomas les c'est ce qui
espère les manifestants un tour de force
finale peut-être le bouquet final
d'ailleurs de cette mobilisation avant
la décision du Conseil constitutionnel
et là on se trouve ici à la place de la
Bastille 4 heures après le départ du
cortège à Opéra et donc la Bastille
derrière c'est derrière moi ces images
de Gaulle mon niveau vous les montrent
voilà les manifestants se disperse
tranquillement mais on a senti en tout
cas que voilà des manifestants toujours
très déterminés la CGT dit 400 000
manifestants tout de même donc en nombre
même si la préfecture de police
évidemment dit 10 fois moins pas de quoi
non plus constater un essoufflement de
cette détermination du côté de
l'intersyndical hors de question pour
eux de parler de barre ou d'honneur
écoutez Sophie Binet de la CGT
qui sont rentrés à nouveau dans la grève
aujourd'hui je pense par exemple aux
salariés des raffineries au secteur du
traitement des déchets j'y étais ce
matin qui ont relancé leurs grèves ce
matin vous allez voir que dans les rues
il y a encore des primo manifestants et
des primaux grévistes après évidemment
c'est la 12e journée donc ça tire parce
que 12 journées de grève ça pèse lourd
dans le porte-monnaie et puis pour
certains c'est 40 journées de grève
parce qu'il y a aussi des grèves
reconductibles qui sont très fortes mais
la détermination des salariés des
travailleuses et des travailleurs et des
jeunes à obtenir le retrait de sa
réforme elle est intacte ça c'est sûr
les manifestants ont surtout en ligne de
mire le Conseil constitutionnel cette
décision attendue demain
évidemment Thomas c'était dans toutes
les têtes et tout à l'heure presque
comme un symbole le cortège est passé à
quelques mètres seulement de la rue de
mon pensier où siège le Conseil
constitutionnel et donc vous le disiez
Thomas les sages rendront demain leur
décision en vue vu partout ça comme le
juge de paix finalement de cette réforme
avec à la clé peut-être une censure de
certaine mesure on s'attend à voir par
exemple l'index senior ou le CDI senior
censuré qui sont des dispositions qui
pourraient être jugées comme des
cavaliers sociaux dans un texte
budgétaire mais les syndicats surtout ne
se font aucune illusion sur le fait
d'une censure de l'article 7 le cœur du
réacteur de la réforme sur le report de
l'âge légal à 64 ans et quand bien même
il serait déçu si l'article 7 n’était
pas censuré et bien il ne contesterait
pas la légitimité de la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel écouter Laurent
Berger
non je vais être très clair là-dessus on
peut pas on peut pas dans notre
démocratie craindre une crise
démocratique craint d'une dérive
démocratique et ne pas respecter les
institutions qui sont notre cadre commun
moi quand je faisais du foot quand je
rentrais sur le terrain il y avait des
règles du jeu toutes me plaisaient pas
forcément mais si je perdais c'est parce
que c'était souvent pas à cause des
règles du jeu
et puis Thomas dans le cortège on a
croisé des parlementaires qui ont mené
la bataille contre la réforme des
retraites au Sénat pour certains comme
Fabien gay qui est un sénateur
communiste de Seine-Saint-Denis et bien
c'était aussi l'occasion de faire un peu
le bilan de ces trois mois de
mobilisation Fabien Guess qui nous a dit
c'est que pour lui le Conseil
constitutionnel qu'ils sont sur ou qu'il
ne s'en sort pas la réforme des
retraites et bien une fracture s'est
créée entre l'exécutif et le peuple
écouté
c'est une crise sans précédent quasiment
c'est à dire que il y a un fossé entre
un gouvernement
ultra minoritaire et le reste la très
grande majorité du peuple français
et à noter aussi Thomas que le Conseil
constitutionnel devra aussi demain
donner son feu vert à un éventuel
référendum d'initiative partagée et là
encore les opposants à la réforme mise
beaucoup sur ce recours merci beaucoup
Jonathan Dupriez à vous coûter je le
rappelle Hugo Lemonnier et puis aussi
Erwan Douillard tiens d'ailleurs à
propos de ce référendum d'initiative
partagé on a une information exclusive
publique Sénat à vous révéler dans dans
quelques minutes mais je vous présente
tout de suite mes invités Bruno cotress
bonsoir Bruno bienvenue vous êtes
politologue chercheur au CNRS et au Sevy
pof j'accue également Pierre Adrien
Bartoli bonsoir bienvenue directeur des
études politiques à l'institut Harris
Interactive Mathilde sirop bonsoir
Mathilde politique et on attend on vous
dit tout Catherine tricot qui ne serait
tarder Catherine tricot la directrice de
la revue regard bon c'est la deuxième
journée de mobilisation Bruno cauteresse
les chiffres sont globalement en baisse
dans toute la France pas seulement à à
Paris aussi de moins en moins de
fonctionnaires en grève ça c'est un
autre éléments de comparaison quel bilan
vous faites de cette moi je disais
ambiance de veiller d'armes voilà tout
le monde est évidemment allé regarde
tourner vers le conseil consonne mais
qu'est-ce que ça dit quand même de la
capacité à mobiliser sur une période
aussi longue et quand même eu des
mobilisation très longue bah oui la
durée de très nombreuses semaines donc
ça veut dire qu'au bout d'un moment il y
a une mécanique absolument normale je
crois qu'il s'enclenche qui a un mélange
à la fois de un peu de résignation aussi
un peu le sentiment que il va falloir
trouver d'autres moyens parce que vous
l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure ça coûte
beaucoup à ceux qui sont en grève le
sentiment qu'on est peut-être arrivé au
bout de ce qu'on pouvait obtenir avec
les manifestations il y a cette attente
de la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel et demain on va franchir
une nouvelle étape il va y avoir une
nouvelle distribution des rôles sans
aucun doute de nouveau nouvelle
modalités d'action et une nouvelle
stratégie aussi de l'interse médicale
une tonalité quand même très légitimiste
disant si on peut pas à la fois se dire
qu'une utilise la démocratie par
respecter les institutions démocratiques
donc ça ça nous donne un avant-goût la
CFDT et sans doute l'Inter syndicale va
devoir trouver de nouvelles modalités de
mobilisation pour maintenir la pression
on verra demain ce que le Conseil
constitutionnel va nous dire à propos de
ce référendum d'initiatives partagées il
y a déjà une date en ligne de mire quel
est le premier mai évidemment d'atte
hautement symbolique pyradrien Bartoli
ce qui est quand même frappant quand on
comme vous on étudie on scrute l'opinion
c'est cette espèce de stabilité depuis
trois mois quoi c'est c'est congelé
c'est cristallisé depuis le début
quasiment on a une toute petite
évolution pour tout vous dire on a un
tout petit baisse de l'opposition mais
vraiment marginale après le vote au
Sénat parce qu'on part des électeurs de
droite assez légitimistes se dire bon ça
a été voté au Sénat c'est pas très
différent de ce à quoi on adhère allez
on va peut-être soutenir un petit peu
plus que ce qu'on avait fait au début
cette réforme et puis 49-3 sa
cristallise ça ça crispe à nouveau les
différentes oppositions et on revient à
ce rapport de qui est toujours le même
depuis le début c'est à dire deux tiers
des Français opposés à la réforme un
tiers favorable en sous-main se joue
quand même un autre aspect qui est un
l'âge de la réforme à quel moment je
vais partir quel est mon avenir
personnellement dans la société mais
surtout quelle est cette société pour
demain et c'est une des raisons qui fait
que c'est positions sont autant crispées
autant cristallisé depuis le début que
n'a quand même un deuxième dès le départ
qui est l'exemple en tout cas une
réforme qui est pris comme l'exemple
d'un pouvoir central coupé de ce qui
peut se passer sur le terrain quand on
interroge des Français dès le début ils
nous disent mais ils vont nous faire
travailler deux ans de plus ils savent
pas ce que c'est de travailler deux ans
plus tout de suite dès le départ les
premiers arguments qui arrivent ce sont
des arguments de d'un pouvoir
déconnecter et évidemment toute la
séquence politique les différentes
prises de parole et la difficulté à
s'entendre est venue renforcer ce
terreau c'est pas illogique que les
choses restent très très stables je
propose à Catherine tricot de nous
rejoindre sur ce plateau bonsoir
Catherine installez-vous je voudrais
quand même qu'on se souvienne mais
peut-être qu'on l'analyse ensemble
bienvenue Catherine de l'interview télé
d'Emmanuel Macron dans les journaux de
13h à quel point ça a été
contre-productivement au 13 dans votre
analyse c'est fortement contre puisque
c'est la combinaison du 49-3 et
l'accentuation dans le pignon dans la
perception de l'option public
l'accentuation de l'idée d'un exécutif
qui se coupe du peuple qui exactement
de au fond de compréhension de ce qui se
passe dans le dans le pays et c'est vrai
que cette interview du du chef de l'État
et sans aucun doute un grand raté du
point de la communication et c'est
l'interaction entre les deux c'est la
combinaison des deux e49.3 et
l'interview qui quelques heures plus
tard ne donne pas du tout le sentiment
que le chef de l'État comprend corrige
le tir mais nous au contraire il en
rajoute même d'une certaine manière il
va figer de ce point de vue là sans
aucun doute les les lignes de partage et
graver sans aucun doute de manière
extrêmement profonde l'idée qui à partir
de là devient presque dominante on ne
parle moins peut-être on beaucoup moins
de l'idée de faire travailler davantage
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire mais c'est
plus le thème le manque de démocratie le
pouvoir qui se coupe du peuple et le
manque de démocratie qui devient presque
le thème dominant et Catherine tricot
avec une question si on se projette dès
maintenant on va évidemment commenter
analyser ce qui pourrait se passer
demain avec le Conseil consuel mais sur
la
capacité de réformer la suite du enfin
avec un 7 cette mobilisation cette
opposition aussi
figée dans le temps ce que vous nous
décriviez elle va laisser des traces
dans l'opinion pour longtemps on peut
l'imaginer là les structuré elle est
ancrée voilà donc je sais pas ce qui va
je pense que ça va pas pouvoir quand on
va pas pouvoir continuer de manifester
toutes les semaines toutes les semaines
toutes les semaines donc quelque chose
va changer forcément
de manifestations c'est quand même 12
journées de mi-journée de travail en
moins de salaire en moins et de
difficultés tout simplement donc ça va
forcément évoluer mais par contre je
pense que le refus est absolument ancré
et je pense que ce que vous avez dit
c'est que ça s'est aussi doublé il y
avait un refus social et puis d'un
difficulté politique majeure avec le
sentiment que le corps intermédiaires
les syndicats ne sont pas le peuple
n'est pas écouté mais tous les relais du
peuple aussi sont se retrouvent mis à
l'écart je pense que le traitement par
exemple de de la CFDT a été très
choquant pour beaucoup de monde parce
que on sait que la CFDT en principe elle
est plutôt prête à discuter dire quoi
qu'on en pense je veux dire on peut être
plus d'accord avec la CGT avec la CFDT
c'est pas la question c'est que le fait
que la CFDT il ait été à ce point
remisez du côté des opposants sans
principe un peu comme on dit la nuit
Pesse est l'extrême gauche oui je fais
des parallèles peut-être un peu
hasardeux mais il y a une espèce de mise
dans un glow comme ça
la nuit pêche et l'extrême gauche et
tous les syndicats sont des opposants
irréductibles avec qui on peut pas
parler bah je pense que ça choque
beaucoup
puisqu'on en est à dresser une espèce de
bilan peut-être de cette mobilisation
qui dure depuis trois mois et qu'on va
passer à partir de demain à une nouvelle
étape comme l'a dit Bruno cautres d'un
point de vue de l'opinion cette
opposition que vous dites structurée
figé au projet de loi sur les retraites
il est logique parce que bien sûr les
Français ne veulent pas obtempérer au
fait de travailler deux ans de plus
est-ce que c'est la durée de cette
opposition dans le temps qui est inédite
ou la proportion on parle autour de 70%
de Français qui sont hostiles
je reviens sur ce qu'on disait et ça va
ça va corroborer ce cet aspect là
ce qui se passe là cette réforme c'est
pas un déclencheur on n'est pas entré
dans un nouveau monde avec des nouvelles
lignes de partage c'est un révélateur
d'ailleurs c'est un énième révélateur
pour être précis de structuration de
l'espace politique qu'on a vu à
l'élection présidentielle et qu'on voit
à nouveau je vous parlais des 1/3 pour
deux tiers contre quand on regarde qui
sont les gens qui sont favorables
sociologiquement on retrouve les plus
âgés on retrouve les cas de les
professions libérales notamment les cas
de supérieures enfin c'est l'électorat
d'Emmanuel Macron et c'est cette France
là qui le suit donc en fait on a un bloc
de Français qui est toujours là qui le
suit dans les enquêtes de confiance de
popularité oui on sent un recul un
effritement de cette popularité
d'Emmanuel Macron mais grosso modo il
tient ses troupes il est encore suivi on
n'est pas du tout sur du François
Hollande enfin de mandat c'est pas du
tout ce qui est en train de se passer le
problème c'est que ça pèse aujourd'hui
grosso modo un tiers des Français et
qu'en face il y a deux tiers des
Français on l'a vu dans les urnes on le
voit dans les enquêtes d'opinion on le
voit là à l'occasion de cette réforme
des retraites qui ont une vision de la
réforme en tant que telle du travail de
l'allongement de la durée de cotisation
mais aussi de ce que doit être la
société qui est différente et ils le
font entendre c'est la séquence dans
laquelle on est alors demain le Conseil
constitutionnel et
entendu évidemment sur la réforme
elle-même le report de l'âge légal les
cavaliers sociaux dont parlait Jonathan
Dupriez dans son intervention tout à
l'heure on y reviendra longuement
évidemment dans ce débat mais il y a
aussi la question du projet de
référendum d'initiative partagée déposé
par les parties de gauche du sénage
propose à terme traduis de nous
rejoindre la formation exclusive de
Public Sénat merci et bravo Tam parce
que la gauche ne va pas en rester là va
y avoir un premier enfin il y avait un
premier RIP préférait un homme
d'initiative partagée et un deuxième RIB
c'est ce que l'on a appris cet
après-midi la gauche a déposé une
deuxième demande de référendum
d'initiative partagée et pourquoi et
bien pour faire face aux risques
d'invalidation demain de la demande de
riz par le Conseil constitutionnel enfin
un tout petit retour en arrière la
gauche a déposé une demande de RIP le 20
mars dernier un texte qui comporte un
seul article un très très court qui vise
à inscrire dans la loi que l'âge de la
retraite je cite ne peut être fixé au
delà de 62 ans et là donc on apprend
qu'elle dépose une deuxième demande de
RIP déjà déposée là sur le bureau du
président du Sénat alors en quoi elle
consiste masse c'est un texte plus
développé plus argumenté au niveau
juridique avec tous les impacts
financiers d'une telle mesure il est
signé par les mêmes parlementaires que
pour le premier ri par le premier RIP
avait réussi en réunir 252 à gauche un
Patrick canner le président du groupe
EPS nous a dit qu'il s'agit de conforter
l'argumentation du premier RIP en clair
on comprend surtout qu'il y a une forte
crainte par rapport au premier qu'il a
sans doute été mal écrit on craint qu'il
soit retoqué demain par le Conseil
constitutionnel car que dit la
Constitution elle dit que le Président
de la République peut soumettre un
référendum des réformes des réformes
relatives à la politique économique
sociale etc de la nation et donc un
article unique pourrait ne pas
correspondre au terme de réforme ce qui
explique que la gauche prépare ce
deuxième texte plus fourni on comprend
donc que demain le premier il pourrait
donc être invalidé la gauche s'y prépare
et n'attend en tout cas pas le vertige
Tod des sages pour proposer une deuxième
copie merci traduit pour ces infos Bruno
kotresse c'est il y a un petit côté
c'est pas très sympa pour les parties de
gauche au Sénat mais un petit côté
amateur quand même dans dans ce qu'on
est en train de décrire alors c'est vrai
que peu d'analystes avaient décelé qui
pouvait y avoir un souci du côté de la
rédaction du projet de de RIP qui avait
été déposé et c'est vrai quand on lisait
de près on disait il peut
potentiellement avoir un petit un petit
souci sur cette sur cette rédaction
parce que tout le monde tout le monde
tout le monde depuis maintenant
plusieurs semaines dit ça ne peut que
passer avec l'idée peut-être que le
Conseil constitutionnel j'aurais une
sorte de jeu d'équilibre en validant une
partie du projet du gouvernement et donc
en contrepartie en validant la demande
dans la faire un homme de manière à ce
que le conseil à la fois dise le droit
et en même temps je joue un rôle
d'équilibre dans une France sous tension
sauf que là cet équilibre pas l'avoir
demain voilà c'est vrai si jamais si
jamais prudent si jamais cette demande
de RIP n'était pas validée demain c'est
vrai que ça l'aiderait un sentiment un
petit d'amateurisme en tout cas de
manque de préparation mais les juges
constitutionnels nous diront s'ils
devaient le sanctionner sur quel point
est-ce que c'est sur un point de détail
est-ce que c'est sur quelque chose de
plus fondamental on ne sait on ne sait
pas ça fera partie des éléments qu'on
suivra demain on sera d'ailleurs en
direct exceptionnellement avant vendredi
à 18h pour vous faire vivre et commenter
la décision des 9 sages de la rue
Montpensier il y a cette réaction parce
que c'est quand même important dans
l'équilibre dont vous nous parliez de
nos contrées cette réaction de Cyril
Chabanier de la CFTC dans la
manifestation tout à l'heure si on si on
n'a pas au moins le référendum
d'initiative partagé alors la colère
sociale va être très forte Catherine
tricot il y a là nous bon voilà on
explique ça nos téléspectateurs sont
évidemment informés de la mécanique
parlementaire ils ont l'habitude qu'on
leur parle mais tous les Français ne
sont pas donc qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
qu'est-ce qui risque de retenir demain
c'est imaginons que le coin alors là
encore on fait un peu de position mais
imaginons qui est validation d'un côté
et rejet du horrible de l'autre là je
pense que je pense qu'on là on va dans
un crise difficile parce qu'il faut
quand même bien trouver une porte de
sortie ce qu'on dit tout à l'heure bon
les le rapport de force semble un peu
figé personne ne va bouger la conviction
qu'il ne faut pas cette réforme est
ancrée donc il faut quand même trouver
une manière de s'en sortir donc moi je
ne sais pas si le
Conseil constitutionnel peut retoquer la
réforme d'ailleurs je trouve ça presque
un peu étrange parce que ça serait comme
une réponse politique une sortie
politique ce que beaucoup disent on en
reparlera de la réforme là je reste sur
la question du référendum pour l'instant
la sortie politique par le fait que la
loi soit retoquée me paraît difficile
par contre la sortie politique par le
fait qu'on donne la parole au peuple ça
ça me semble être quelque chose que tout
le monde entre voit comme une solution
de bon sens que peut-être même Emmanuel
Macron aurait pu
mais je n'ai prendre même si c'est bien
qui va perdre mais il faut quand même
sortir on va pas rester dans cette
situation faut que quelqu'un prenne une
initiative et je trouve ça étrange que
l'initiative soit simplement du côté du
Conseil constitutionnel c'est
[Musique]
on est dans une mobilisation et si les
choses se mettent en place assez vite
les corps intermédiaires les syndicats
les parties d'opposition peuvent essayer
de transformer ce potentiel qui existe
ça c'est une évidence en signature mais
ça veut dire la communication presque
même de la de la publicité quoi enfin
c'est une campagne de com qui faut
engager comment vous l'imaginez oui et
c'est même au-delà de ça parce que quand
on regarde par exemple l'écart qu'on a
entre le soutien dans l'opinion
l'opposition d'ailleurs pour être précis
le soutien à ce mouvement et sa
concrétisation dans la rue l'écart est
immense on a très peu de gens en
relatifs qui vont manifester par rapport
à ceux qui qui sont opposés à la réforme
quelle est la part qui va aller
participer à ce référendum qui est
relativement inédit que les gens vont
pas connaître qu'il y a une modalité
d'expression qui est nouvelle sur la
forme et qui en plus c'est pas tellement
ancré dans nos habitudes politiques en
France quand bien même il y aura un
soutien dans la population qui serait
beaucoup plus large ça reste une
inconnue et je pense qu'il faut pas trop
s'avancer je veux bien vous entendre
là-dessus Catherine d'abord et puis
ensuite je viens de je pense que c'est
pas une affaire simple de recueillir 4
millions 8 ça ne s'est jamais fait en
France je veux dire on n'a jamais
atteint une plus de 1 million et demi
c'est où l'affaire du siècle un million
donc c'est quand même très difficile de
faire 4 millions et 8 mais surtout ce
que je pense et que ça mettrait ça
continuerait d'entretenir le mouvement
de mobilisation et ça veut dire qu'on ne
sort pas ça qu'on fait du surplace on
reste qu'on reste dans cette situation
bloquée donc ça ne résout pas le
problème en tout cas du côté du
gouvernement il se trouve devant un os
qui fait qu'il faut bien qu'il prenne
une initiative pour en sortir c'est pour
ça que je moi je crois que il débouche
d'une certaine manière ou pas sur les 4
millions 8 c'est un fait politique
d'ailleurs Aéroport de Paris la
privatisation a été stoppée ils n'ont
pas eu les 4 millions de de signatures
mais le simple dynamique de ce
référendum avait suffi à arrêter le
processus donc moi je pense que si le
processus est validé au Conseil
constitutionnel d'une part ça va compte
entretenir le feu et d'autre part ça va
faire un événement politique ça va voilà
et avec Bruno cotterez dans ce même dans
cette même enquête une large très large
majorité de Français qui espèrent que
parce que il y aura la perspective du
référendum d'initiative partagée le
prénom République ne promulgue pas la
loi même si elle est validée par le
Conseil constitutionnel ça il y a une
question de démocratie enfin vous
employez tout à l'heure et notamment de
démocratie participative ou une nouvelle
forme de démocratie donc est-ce que ça
ça plaît pas quand même même si j'ai
entendu vos arguments pour une large
participation des Français c'est plus
facile de peut-être signer sur internet
que de perdre une demi-journée ou une
journée de travail en allant manifester
oui c'est sans doute une des grandes
questions parce que
je pense que le chef de l'État sans
doute promulguera
je n'imagine pas Emmanuel Macron à
l'issue de tout ce processus ne pas
promulguer nous disant bah finalement
j'ai bien réfléchi finalement l'idée de
la pause donc on ne voit pas cet
argumentaire donc on peut y faire le de
70 ou 80% de l'État va promulguer il
faudra aussi quel est l'effet de cette
remuation sur la dynamique de signature
pour le pour le pot pour le riz par
ailleurs il y a un délai de 9 mois qui
lui est incompressible ça même s'il est
10 % du collectoral était instantanément
obtenu il faut quand même que ça dure
pendant 9 mois et derrière il y a encore
une nouvelle étape qui est quand même
que cette cette demande de RIB doit
venir devant les assemblées que si le
chef de l'État ne la demande pas de
n'organise pas une nouvelle délibération
devant les assemblées là il y a
automatiquement procédure de référendum
et donc ce que vous nous dites bien
c'est que le référendum et même et pas
automatique c'est à dire que même si
elle est 4800000 il peut automatique le
chef d'État peut décider de passer par
l'Assemblée et uniquement par
l'Assemblée on est bien d'accord les
effets cumulés de toutes ces
informations parce que pour le moment
beaucoup pensent que on a on a 10% le
chef de l'état d'une certaine manière il
peut y avoir un effet déceptif quoi donc
voilà il faut d'avoir l'effet de cette
information parce que je ne doute pas
d'une part que que les syndicats vont
beaucoup faire campagne mais je ne doute
pas que le gouvernement lui-même va
faire campagne en maintenant son optique
et ses prises de position alors Emmanuel
Macron tant la main à l’inter syndical
c'est ce qui a rappelé le porte-parole
du gouvernement en écoute Olivier Véran
cherchons évidemment l'apaisement le
dialogue cela a été montré puisque la
première ministre a reçu
l'intersyndicale il y a quelques jours
encore et le président de la République
l'a annoncé lui-même a fait savoir qu'il
était disposé près à discuter avec les
forces syndicales de notre pays pour
parler avec eux pour dialoguer pour
échanger dans un groupe dans un climat
apaisé de ce qui nous reste à accomplir
pour réformer notre pays et notamment en
matière de travail d'emploi de bon
emploi de qualité de vie au travail et
puis alors Mathilde dans la dans les
mots employés parmi les mots employés
par le chef d'État et aussi échanger
dans un esprit de concorde et oui Thomas
après trois mois de conflits ouverts
entre le gouvernement et les syndicats
et la rue sur les retraites place donc à
la Concorde c'est ce qu'on pourrait
appeler l'appel d'Amsterdam qui a eu
lieu hier de la part du chef de l'État
on rappelle quand même qu'il y a une
semaine tout pile ce même Emmanuel
Macron envoyé des pics et ciblés de
façon très virulente Laure berger on en
a d'ailleurs parlé sur ce plateau et
voilà maintenant qu'il convie les
syndicats à l'Élysée et c'est depuis la
capitale des Pays-Bas qu'il a donc
initié ce changement de ton un préalable
l'avenir nous le dira peut-être un
tournant stratégique pour lui puisque on
l'a dit après avoir théorisé des sa
campagne de 2016 la faiblesse des corps
intermédiaires et donc des syndicats
après avoir été accusés aussi de
mépriser et de malmener le dialogue
social il n'a d'autre choix aujourd'hui
pour essayer de reprendre la main que
d'en passer par un temps d'apaisement
avec ces syndicats une sorte d'aveu de
faiblesse de la part du président oui un
peu comme si Emmanuel Macron se trouvait
pris à son propre piège ce pas de deux
qui se passe avec les syndicats nous
fait aussi penser à ce qui est à l'œuvre
habituellement avec les partis
politiques considérées de gouvernement
ou en tout cas ce qu'il en reste ni
droite ni gauche pour gagner en 2017 fin
des clivages puis une stratégie de
débauchage permanent côté partie
socialiste côté les républicains durant
son premier mandat et résultat 6 ans
plus tard Emmanuel Macron se retrouve à
essayer de pactiser notamment avec les
républicains pour faire passer sa
réforme des retraites ça a été un échec
il les a tellement affaiblis ça a été un
échec son propre piège qui se referme
sur lui et aujourd'hui donc après ce
conflit pour continuer à gouverner il
essaye voilà de tendre la main on l'a
entendu donc du côté de la droite de la
gauche même jusqu'aux écologistes qui
considéraient comme raisonnable ou
compatible alors on ne sait pas encore
Thomas si il y aura un nouveau départ
avec les syndicats ni celui-ci ni si
celui-ci est encore possible mais en
tout cas du côté politique on voit bien
que Emmanuel Macron semble avoir
les ressorts de la de la séduction
d'ailleurs s'il y a un remaniement
d'ailleurs Elisabeth borne y est
favorable pour essayer de retrouver une
autorité politique si elle est maintenue
à son poste le vivier des des prises de
guerre paraît bien mince aujourd'hui et
puis donc après cette proposition cet
échange qui permettra d'engager la suite
et de tenir compte du verdict du Conseil
constitutionnel je cite Emmanuel Macron
il y a eu la réponse de Sophie Binet la
secrétaire général la nouvelle
secrétaire général de la CGT ça tient en
trois lettres lol j'avais envie de
j'avais envie de dire lol et vous vous
comprenez sa réaction Catherine tricot à
Sophie Binet dirons-nous l'invitation
dans les mêmes termes que Elizabeth
borne d'ailleurs ça va la même chose va
produire les mêmes effets c'est à dire
qu'ils vont peut-être y aller tous
ensemble probablement iront-ils tous
ensemble et il y a eu entre temps
validation par le Conseil
constitutionnel ça change un peu la
donne quand même pourquoi ça change la
donne l'opposition tout à l'heure
non mais ça change quelle est la
démocratie respecter la démocratie ne
veut pas dire ne pas contester une loi
je veux dire c'est on n'est pas en
dehors de la démocratie parce qu'on
comptait c'est une loi donc il
continueront de contester cette loi il
veut il le feront dans le respect de la
démocratie ils vont bien sûr ne pas
brûler les poubelles dans les rues je ne
sais mais je ne crois pas que les
syndicats vont lâcher l'affaire pas du
tout peut-être se diviser en revanche
franchement
de Sophie Binet on verra on verra mais
bien sûr que c'est le rang berger se
féminin ne raconte pas exactement les
choses de la même manière mais en tout
cas je pense que les l'ensemble des
syndicats sont déterminés à ne pas
laisser passer cette réforme qui
prolonge de deux ans l'âge de de enfin
la durée du travail donc sur ça il y
aura sur ça ça va pas céder et donc
c'est pour ça que je pense que vraiment
Emmanuel Macron est coincé qu'il a
besoin de trouver et quand il dit on va
discuter d'autres choses et de la suite
mais non il y aura pas de suite donc ce
point-là restera sur la table justement
pour essayer d'évaluer
la capacité finalement puisque là vous
nous dit Emmanuel Macron prêt à son
propre piège la capacité d'Emmanuel
Macron peut-être à un styler un peu de
division au sein de cette interditale
qui est unie comme jamais c'est c'est
quand même historique dans notre pays
que ça ait duré aussi longtemps une
unité syndicale face à un projet de loi
je vous propose d'écouter une une autre
réaction celle de Fabien Villedieu qui
est délégué syndical Sud Rail et il est
sur un piquet de grève gare de Lyon
évidemment demain il y a le Conseil
constitutionnel qui va donner son avis
nous on le dit cash et direct quel que
soit la vie du Conseil constitutionnel
sauf si il requête la loi 19 de la loi
n'est pas constitutionnelle nous assurer
et nous un solidaire on continuera la
mobilisation alors votre avis Bruno
est-ce que vous êtes sur la d'accord et
Catherine trikel que nous dit de grosso
modo
il y aura une forme de d'unité syndicale
qui va durer ou est-ce que quand même on
va peut-être commencer à voir quelques
fissures apparaître après la décision du
conséquentionnelle c'est difficile de le
dire aujourd'hui on voit
qu'effectivement pour les syndicats il y
a un bien très précieux qui est issu de
toute la séquence qui est cette unité
syndicale et moi je trouve que de ce
point de vue là les syndicats ont une
sorte de pépite en or entre les mains il
va falloir voir ce qu'ils veulent en
faire parce que pour c'est vrai que
c'est assez rare
ça souligne par rapport aux partis
politiques on disait tout à l'heure vous
avez la comparaison entre les deux
dans les syndicats donc je pense que
dans un premier temps ils vont sans
doute réfléchir à deux ou trois fois
avant de se relancer vers la division
oui puis la CFDT il y a un mandat qui a
été donné quand même très clairement
lors du dernier congrès qui a été donné
à berger de ne pas céder et je pense que
il ne peut pas non plus se défaire de ce
mandat qui lui a été donné et il faut se
souvenir que quand la CFDT quand il y a
eu des sessions à l'intérieur de cet été
c'était sur la question des retraites
notamment donc en fait le fait que ça
puisse tanguer très très fort à
l'intérieur de la CFDT si la CFDT
sortait de la mobilisation encore une
fois faudra trouver les moyens de la
mobilisation mais je pense qu'il y a
même une question vous l'avez dit à
l'égard de l'opinion publique mais même
interne à la CFDT c'est que la CFDT elle
est unine et syndiquée donc au delà même
de ce que penserait Laurent Berger les
syndicats ont donné un mandat très clair
et je pense pas que Laurent Berger
puisse s'en détacher alors si on parle
de l'opinion on vous propose ce sondage
Ifop avec cette question on se place
dans la perspective d'un conseil
sélectionner qui valide le texte est-ce
que vous souhaitez ou non l'arrêt du
mouvement social les Français en sondage
sont très partagés 48% de de oui donc 40
rue pur sang qui souhaitent l'arrêt de
mouvement social 52% de nous et puis
alors si on rentre un peu dans le détail
plus par âge c'est intéressant de voir
que
61% des 65 ans et plus souhaite l'arrêt
du mouvement encore une fois si
validation par le Conseil
constitutionnel et 31% seulement parmi
les Français âgés de 18 à 24 ans Pierre
Adrien Bartoli est-ce qu'on est là
finalement vous nous avez décrit une
opinion un peu figée depuis trois mois
est-ce que voilà cette bascule qui n'est
pas intervenu elle peut intervenir là
vous en êtes pas sûr non je suis pas sûr
on verra mais je vois pas trop que ce
qu'il a ce qu'il a motivé en fait
la situation très figée depuis le départ
elle tourne pas autour de la question de
la légalité du texte ce qui va être
tranché demain par le Conseil
constitutionnel elle porte sur la
légitimité du gouvernement de présenter
ce type de texte dans le contexte actuel
dans son dimensionnement tel qu'il a été
présenté etc et ça ça a pas tellement
bougé le désaccord qui est évoqué ici un
désaccord de fond la forme ça en rajoute
sa crise mais au départ les Français ne
sont pas d'accord avec ce projet et
l'incarnation de ce désaccord dans les
sondages c'est l'opposition le soutien
aux manifestants etc pourquoi est-ce que
suite à une décision du Conseil
constitutionnel tout d'un coup les
choses changeraient ça peut arriver mais
ça me paraît relativement peu probable
honnêtement alors je vous propose un
gros plan justement sur ce Conseil
constitutionnel tam-trani va revenir sur
ce plateau bonsoir
avec une question toute simple qui
sont-ils qui sont telles qui sont
personnalités dont les parcours sont
aujourd'hui analysés décortiqués depuis
déjà plusieurs jours on va commencer par
les profils plutôt techniques on les
voit s'afficher qui pose pas trop de
problèmes Michel Pinault fonctionnaire
ancien conseiller d'État nommé par
Gérard Larcher Corinne Lucien au
fonctionnaire ancienne secrétaire
général de l'Assemblée nationale nommé
par Claude bartholon quand il présidait
l'Assemblée ou encore François senère
lui aussi au fonctionnaire ancien
directeur de cabinet de ministres les
deux derniers ont tout de même un rôle
important dans la séquence actuelle car
ils ont été nommés rapporteur pour le
Conseil constitutionnel dans l'examen
des recours contre la réforme des
retraites alors il y a aussi des profils
plus politiques qui ont été critiqués et
oui celui par exemple de Véronique
Malbec elle est pourtant en magistrate
mais c'est aussi l'ex directrice de
cabinet d'Eric Dupond-Moretti et surtout
se l'avait suscité des critiques car
elle avait été nommée par Richard
Ferrand qui présidait alors l'Assemblée
nationale et il y avait eu des soupçons
de renvoi d'ascenseur et puis vous
l'avez dit allez profils vraiment
politiques l'ex sénateur elle est à
François Pilet deux anciens Premier
ministre ministre Alain Juppé Laurent
Fabius enfin deux anciens ministres
d'Emmanuel Macron Jacques mesard et
Jacqueline Gourault et c'est évidemment
sur ces deux derniers profils que se
concentre les critiques de l'opposition
c'est une instance très politique dit
certains écoutaient Alexis Corbière
député la France insoumise et Marine Le
Pen qui préside maintenant le groupe du
Rassemblement national à l'Assemblée
ministre deux anciens ministres
gouvernement Macron vous avez affaire à
des juges vous voyez quand vous êtes au
tribunal face à vous vous n'avez pas des
personnalités qui ont été politiques il
y a constitution la composition du
Conseil constitutionnel qui est une
composition faite de gens qui sont
nommés par des politiques
fondamentalement au-delà de ce conseil
constitutionnels là peut-être mériterait
une réflexion pour qu'il y ait des gens
vous dites que si jamais vous arriviez
au pouvoir vous changeriez le
fonctionnement mais en tout cas il faut
réfléchir peut-être à ce que les membres
du Conseil constitutionnel soit
véritablement totalement détachés
totalement indépendant dans leur
nomination des ce qui pourrait permettre
alors plus explicite encore la tribune
de l'économiste de gauche Thomas picetti
dans le monde qu'il dit qu'il ne faut
pas trop en attente du Conseil
constitutionnel je cite ces mots ces
institutions précieuses et fragiles sont
parfois instrumentalisées et abîmé par
les personnes auxquelles ces fonctions
éminentes ont été confiées et qui
tentent souvent d'imposer leur propre
préférence politique sous le couvert du
droit alors on a vu des attaques
politiques de l'opposition qu'en pensent
les les constitutionnalistes les experts
certains sont tout aussi sévères c'est
le cas de la professeure de droit public
Laureline fontaine qui parle d'une
grande complaisance avec les majorités
politiques successives et plusieurs
experts de la Constitution disent tout
de même qu'en gros on pourrait mieux
faire écouter et bien le
constitutionnaliste Bertrand Mathieu
aucun mode de nomination qui n'est
parfait dans beaucoup de pays les
membres du Conseil constitutionnel sont
nommés par le Parlement c'est encore
plus politisé ce qui peut poser problème
c'est qu'en sont nommé au Conseil
constitutionnel des personnalités qui
viennent d'exercer immédiatement
auparavant une fonction politique par
exemple de ministre par exemple Bertrand
Mathieu propose lui qu'il y ait un délai
à un délai observe un délai de carence
pour avoir le temps de retirer sa veste
politique parce qu'on a été ministre
pour revêtir ses habits de sages et
s'habituer au costume car je rappelle
que les sages ensuite et bien ils
prêtent serment ils jurent de bien et
finalement remplir leurs fonctions et
les exercer en toute impartialité dans
le respect de la Constitution ainsi que
de garder le secret des délibérations et
des votes est-ce bien le cas et bien
certains ont des doutes le monde par
exemple dans un article publié fin mars
relatait ainsi que l'ancien ministre
Jacques mesard rendait compte
discrètement à Emmanuel Macron de
l'activité du Conseil merci Tam pour ces
informations
il y a aussi un sondage qui est paru
aujourd'hui un Français sur deux
seulement fait confiance aux conseils
constitutionnel pour je les cite pour
enfin c'était l'intitulé de la question
évidemment pour rendre des décisions
impartiales là on rentre dans la
question de la légitimité et on est au
cœur vous l'avez un peu évoqué mais on
est vraiment au cœur de de débat depuis
des semaines donc ça vous dites quoi
légitimité faible pour le Conseil
constitutionnel ou c'est un peu radical
de dire ça c'est vrai que le Conseil
constitutionnel a souvent été souvent
été le l'objet de commentaires ou de
soupçons sur son sur sa partialité il
était longtemps perçu comme le défenseur
de la loi et de l'ordre celui qui va
systématiquement valider des mesures qui
sont des mesures qui vont dans le sens
d'une politique de maintien de l'ordre
public par exemple et c'est vrai qu'on a
un souci qui est le statut de cette de
cette institution c'est pas l'équivalent
de la Cour suprême américaine
c'est ce sont des juges constitutionnels
néanmoins en même temps peu d'entre eux
sont de véritables juristes si on ne
nommait que des juristes on dirait c'est
le gouvernement des juges il faut un
regard politique sur on peut pas
simplement rendre le droit en apesanteur
il faut citerne du contexte politique
donc voilà on voit qu'il y a un sujet de
réflexion un plus sur un mécanisme des
institutions qui qui ne donne pas
pleinement le sentiment qu'on peut s'en
remettre à lui et ça n'est que un parmi
parce que vous avez cité la la confiance
dans le Conseil constitutionnel qui est
qui est assez tiède on va dire les
choses comme ça mais il y a beaucoup
d'institutions la confiance est plus
faible l'Assemblée nationale par exemple
niveau de confiance et de l'ordre de 35
à 40% grand maximum l'institution
présidentielle même quand on la
décorelle du titulaire de la fonction
présidentielle le niveau de confiance
n'est pas très élevé et au fond les
seuls institutions dans lesquelles les
Françaises et les Français ont confiance
ce sont les institutions de proximité
c'est les institutions publiques qui
incarnent le soin les hôpitaux par
exemple le système de santé ou alors la
proximité les élus les élus loc voilà un
sujet supplémentaire et il faudra bien
un moment donné qui est quand même
enfin une réflexion sur pour quelles
raisons les Françaises et les Français
regardent de manière aussi négative des
institutions capitales centrales
gouvernement Parlement court
constitutionnel on est au cœur de la
machine
Bartoli ce qui est sûr c'est que bon
cette décision elle va être
particulièrement scrutée demain c'est
devenu un événement politique ce qui est
pas forcément le cas on a recherché il y
a eu des il y a eu des des décisions un
peu surprises la taxe carbone qui a été
retoquée par exemple on est on est dans
la en pleine trêve des confiseurs je me
souvenais plus de la date c'est 29
décembre 2009 à l'époque donc de Nicolas
Sarkozy la loi logement social de ces
sites Duflot là on est sous François
Hollande ou alors la promesse de
campagne de François Hollande avec un
pot à 75% pour
ceux qui avaient plus d'un million
d'euros qui avait également été retoqué
par le conseil donc on sait pas mais
tout le monde dit la loi enfin la
réforme va être peut-être validé en
partie au toquée mais globalement validé
on peut-être une surprise demain on
verra bien mais on peut pas totalement
balayer l'hypothèse d'un rejet du texte
ah non ah non on peut pas balayer cette
hypothèse là c'est pas impossible pour
le mot c'est le rôle du Conseil
constitutionnel de nous dire demain ce
qu'il en sera mais il est pas il jugeant
droit par nos interrompre mais il est
pas insensible à la pression de la rue
quoi
imaginé le départ il dit le droit dans
un contexte c'est ça le Conseil
constitutionnel c'est pas uniquement
effectivement quelqu'un qui dit le droit
complètement décoré de ce qui est de ce
qui se passe non ce qui est intéressant
c'est de se dire pourquoi est-ce qu'on
attend avec autant d'impatience cette
décision et pourquoi est-ce qu'on l'a
transformé en événement politique ça
devrait pas être un événement politique
bon ça a été à d'autres occasions c'est
pas inédit mais néanmoins ça devrait pas
être un événement politique parce qu'au
fond tout le monde cherche un déboucher
un déboucher politique évidemment à la
séquence pour l'instant on l'a pas
trouvé ni du côté du gouvernement ni du
côté des syndicats pour le moment le
rôle de trou de faire la porte de sortie
et donc on focalise sur cet événement là
parce que c'est l'étape suivante de cet
espace pèse de réforme Netflix où on
attend chaque épisode suivant pour
savoir ce qui va se passer à défaut
d'avoir une autre porte de sortie le 13h
d'Emmanuel Macron devait dresser des
perspectives pour enjamber cette fin de
séquence ça a pas marché et pour
l'instant on n'a pas d'autres
alternatives si vous deviez faire un
pari Catherine tricot vous diriez quoi
sur la décision de quoi c'est
cautionnelle demain le rappel que vous
venez de faire de toutes les lois qu'il
a retoquées montrent en effet que c'est
quand même plutôt une assemblée très
sage et de maintien de l'ordre et pas
simplement d'un ordre au sens de l'ordre
de l'ordre public mais aussi de l'ordre
économique il est quand même tendance
libérale voire néolibéral enfin on le
rappelle que vous avez dit par exemple
les 75% qui avaient été retoqués de la
promesse de François Hollande de taxer
les plus hauts revenus c'était quand
même pas grand chose et ça ça n'était
pas passé donc moi j'en attends j'en ai
pas grand espoir ceci étant Laurent
Fabius avait donné un interview au début
janvier dans lequel je vous disais on
s’est psychisme sur le choix de faire
cette réforme à travers une réforme de
la Sécurité sociale le rend Fabius
président de Conseil constitutionnel
donc lui en tant que président de
Conseil constitutionnel il disait il y a
quand même une bizarrerie que ce soit à
travers une noire portant modification
du budget de la Sécurité sociale qui
venait d'être voté un mois avant donc on
voyait bien l'entourloupe des riz il y a
quand même eu une entourloupe juridique
avec cette loi et peut-être que ça il y
a en effet un désaccord de fond et puis
il y a quelque chose qui déplaît à tout
le monde c'est qu'on s'est dit non mais
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette histoire
pourquoi ils l'ont fait de cette manière
de façon aussi rapide brutale en coupant
en cours au débat etc bon c'est
tellement devenu un événement politique
que on sera en direct demain à 18h pour
une édition spéciale de de ce sens
public pour vous informer sur la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat sur Public Sénat à bientôt